they need covid and because they need
covid you can see it's sort of leaking
back into the system right now so uh
here is jen saki
and you literally she's just a liar go i
will tell you that the vice president
has been wearing a mask inside when
there was a private greet they were all
wearing masks uh
uh
before they went i'm wearing a mask
yesterday at the senate
she was uh playing an important role in
in confirming or overseeing the
confirmation of the first black woman at
the supreme court
okay so first off um kamala harris does
not wear masks indoors when there's no
cameras obviously
enough of the theater
if you believe that then i've got a
bridge to sell you like look behind the
curtain guys
it ain't this big scary eyes guy it's an
old beat up wizard that's all that's
left okay of old beat up failed
scientist it's something like that if
you think kamala harris is doing that
let's not forget it was only a couple
weeks ago that all of those geriatric
old buffoons were all in a windowless
uh
congress right they were all at the
capitol
during the state of the union
and they were hugging and sniffing hair
and doing everything else that they
would do so please
saki you're a liar obviously kamala
harris is not just she just yes she's
always indoors with masks is that even
the guidance anymore i'm not even sure
that's the guidance as per that schmuck
fouchy okay that's number one number two
did you catch what she said there at the
end well yesterday she took the mask off
because she was playing an important
role in something so when something's
seriously important when you're got a
black supreme court justice coming in
then of course covid can't be spread
which is the same drivel
that these crazy people were telling you
when they had you masked up but then
there's a black lives matter rally and
we're burning down portland so take off
your mask that's literally what they
were doing remember laurie lightfoot the
uh the spitting image of health remember
when she uh took off her mask so that
she could rally in chicago because you
know we have to do it
we have to do it because if you're
protesting racism you can't get covet
anyway they lie about everything and
they also don't want you to take masks
off on planes which is patently
ridiculous and by the way i'm seeing
more and more people just go ahead and
do it which is that's your right as an
american to fight the power man uh dana
perrino my friend dana perino over on
fox she asked sake about the airplane
mask mandate speaking of covet in about
eight days the cdc is supposed to
release information
or release a decision on whether
americans will continue to have to wear
masks on airlines does the president
have a view does he want to see
americans be able to
lift those masks off their faces as they
try to travel and get back to some
normalcy
well the president's going to wait and
see what the cdc recommends and as you
said we don't have too much more time to
wait for that so we'll we'll learn more
in the coming days
god i really hate her like hate's not
good
i try not to thrive on hate a lot of
people do
i don't run with hate but when we do the
run through of the show we do a quick
run-through where we run through all the
clips i cannot i actually have to tell
the guys okay i got it i can't even
watch her anymore i find her so vile so
soulless and your ability to lie and
just there's nothing real about her
whatsoever so she'll be a perfect host
on msnbc which is where she's going as
you know when she leaves the white house
gig anyway as far as the plane situation
first off saki does not wear masks on
planes let's be clear she's usually
flying on air force one or some other
government plane or private plane and if
you think she's wearing a mask it's the
same thing as joe he gets off the
helicopter they've shown the videos
where he puts the mask on as he gets off
to walk on the grass because he doesn't
even know what he's doing right um they
lie about that we're also told
constantly you've all been on a plane
what do they always show you on a plane
they show you either an animation or a
very fake looking person and they've got
spray in the air is 99.999
filtered and it's the safest one
okay so is that is that all just a lie
could anyone release any numbers related
to people that got coveted on planes has
that not been released no no numbers on
that fouch you got any numbers no
nothing
nothing to talk about the point is if
you want to wear a mask on a plane fine
wear a mask i highly recommend it if you
want to put a plastic bubble
on your head
do not drink water do not eat food but
the rest of this is pure [ __ ]
covered can spread whether you're eating
peanuts although peanuts will kill you
too on a plane uh or whether you're
having a dry wrap because the wraps are
always dry aren't they always dry you
get a wrap on a plane it's always dry
a little mayo people
uh it's all just endless nonsense just
endless nonsense